how long does it take to learn to be an
entrepreneur so I got a great question
for one of my newer youtube subscribers
love you guys nazareth wrote in to say i
just graduated from high school I want
to study business be an entrepreneur I
want to learn from others experiences
and get a part-time job for you how many
years does it take for you to learn
everything to have those experiences so
this is a great question and I'm a big
believer that if you want to start a
business and you don't know anything
about that industry go learn from a
company who's already doing it because
you're going to make mistakes while
getting paid you're going to make
important industry connections you're
going to figure out if this is something
that you want to do or not sometimes you
look at something from the outside Wow
I'd love to do that and you get into it
say oh my I can't believe I wanted to do
this right so it's a great opportunity
to go learn get paid to do it make
mistakes are getting paid learn the best
practices and then build up a client
base or build up connection so when you
go and launch your own company you're
off and running you know what you're
doing how long does that take this is a
great question and there's no hard and
fast rule the difference is going to be
in the quality of the apprenticeship
that you get what i mean by that is you
could go work 10 years of a company and
never get any really important role with
them right if you're going to start off
your high school graduate just now you
you know you might set up you can work
with some companies just be fetching
coffee sir people running errands and
photocopying you know that's that's not
that's not going to teach you anything
about the industry that might look good
on a resume to say hey you worked with
this big company but that's not going to
teach you anything if your goal is to go
launch your own business then it's not
going to work at some big company where
you're giving crappy jobs to get started
so you can work many many years and not
learn anything on the flip side your
best opportunity is to work with a
smaller company when you're working with
with an entrepreneur entrepreneurs
always have stuff that needs to get done
right we're never sitting there like I
have I have so much free time on my
hands I wonder what I could do right it
work we're crazy we're working like
crazy
always need help and so what I would try
to do is think about the type of
business that you want to start now I
have an entire zucca guide that walks
through this step-by-step and helps you
figure this out but this is kind of like
summarize it's called it's called work
to learn but that is the summarized
version go find the company that is
doing exactly what you want to do okay
and I look for company with ten
employees or less you want a small
company ten employees or less and go
work with them and get as close to the
entrepreneur founder as possible so when
you go you're going to get you're going
to get hired to do a certain set of
tasks right this is what you're going to
be hard to do XYZ but there's always
going to be opportunities it's always
going to be other things that need to be
done in that company and that's what you
want to sign up to do you want to get as
close to the founder as possible and
anytime something needs to get done at
that business you want to volunteer you
want to come with ideas and how you can
make the business stronger you want to
help out if it after hours free time
whatever it is just to get involved
because you're you're taking this job
not for the money but you're taking it
to learn so the more you can it get
involved with the entrepreneur who has
to deal with everything of running the
business then the faster your education
is going to be and maybe you're only
there six months maybe really there a
year before you learn what you need to
launch your business so it's much more
about the quality of the experience and
who you're working with in the size of
their business and the projects that
they give you the work on much more
important then how long we spend because
if you working at the wrong company
you're not going to be a good experience
good luck and believe those you watching
I love to hear if you've ever gone
through an internship program or if you
have a mentor who's helped you along the
way or what you've done to learn from
people who've gone through this ahead of
you leave it in the comments below so
you can help inspire other entrepreneurs
to we're facing the same problems you
guys like this video give it a thumbs up
below subscribe to the channel by
clicking on my face thank you guys so
much and I'll see you soon
you